in today's money watch we've got some
timely advice on taxes if you're filing
at the last minute and if you're
listening to me now and you haven't
filed you are the deadline to submit
your taxes for 2021 or ask for an
extension is just a few days away monday
april 18th as of april 1st more than 63
million of your fellow americans have
got refunds from the irs and the average
refund get this more than 3
200
that is up 11.5 from last year and it
could help with inflation cbs news's
business analyst jill schlesinger joins
us now jill thank you for being here uh
if you haven't filed your taxes yet what
should you do take a deep breath file
electronically and you know this check
double check triple track you know the
biggest errors are things like inverting
a social security number or signature if
you are clinging to your paper returns
it's going to take longer so please try
to do electronic but if you are doing
paper check the mailing address the irs
says people send their returns to the
wrong place if people have plans this
weekend other than collating receipts
and filing taxes what should they do
about an extension so you file for an
extension right on the irs website
irs.gov it's a great website and the
form that you are looking for and it'll
be right there is 48.68 that is giving
you six months extra to file your taxes
but here's the little caveat about this
part yes okay you have to pay if you
think you owe taxes even if you're on
extension so you got to do this work
anyway and if you don't the government
will charge you interest on what you owe
and penalties however if they owe you
money there's no interest so you might
as well grab it uh tell me about that
people are getting a lot of money this
year yeah i mean so you have 3 200
that's coming in on average and people
keep saying what do i do with this money
so number one you may want to keep it on
hand we have four decade highs in
inflation and according to government
data this is costing the average
american an extra 350 or 400 bucks a
month
exactly so you may need that but let's
say you've got enough money you know my
big three i say this all the time please
have an emergency reserve fund you know
things are going to continue to be
expensive two pay down debt get ready to
pay down those student loans that's
going to happen at some point and three
try to put money into a retirement
account i think this is an important
thing a lot of people by the way if
you're going on extension you don't get
an extension to put money into an ira or
a roth ira you still have to do that by
the april 18th deadline so please pay
attention to that if you can do it so
people could pour it into a new business
they've started a lot of americans have
done that during the pandemic if you
started a new business in the 2021 tax
year what should you keep in mind well
what you should keep in mind is no one
is withholding taxes for you and that
means you may need to make quarterly
estimates of your tax bill and it's a
drag i get it but go on to the website
you'll have worksheets there you can
figure out either how much you owe what
your actual estimate should be four
quarterly estimates will keep you out of
problems so you say don't call the irs
if you have questions what do you do
then uh you go on to that you go onto
the website the irs received 282 million
calls last year and they answered 11 of
them so let's not call them so go to the
website websites they're catching on
jill thank you very much